susan rice former President Obama
National Security Advisor Susan Rice is
becoming the Republican surveillance
scapegoat you might remember she
received a lot of scrutiny after all of
the Benghazi stuff she's back on the
radar of Republicans Republicans are now
accusing Susan Rice of selectively
pursuing the identities of Americans
involved in surveillance of the trump
team as well as foreign contact using
her basically as a scapegoat to distract
from the actual Russia scandal which is
potential collusion between Donald Trump
and Russian agents now Susan Rice has
been defending herself saying all of her
conduct surrounding these surveillance
operations was appropriate it was
necessary let's take a look at this
short clip Oh Andrew this is not
anything political has had been alleged
the allegation is that somehow Obama
administration officials utilized
intelligence for political purposes
right rice has also been basically
accused of leaking trump team names
discovered from surveillance let's go to
clip number two did you seek the names
of people involved in to unmask the
names of people involved in the trunk
transition the Trump campaign people
surrounding the president the
president-elect let me begin order to
spy on them and absolutely both
absolutely not for any political
purposes to spy expose anything but let
me take the name of Mike Flynn i leaked
nothing to nobody Republicans and
trumpets you can see them Pat
desperately grabbing for anyone or
anything they can use to detract from
what's going on the investigation the
damage this is doing to their party and
to Donald Trump just like the Obama
wiretaps me claims that Donald Trump
started floating on Twitter and know
what we found out about the Trump team
getting incidentally caught up in
foreign surveillance does not mean that
trumps wiretap tweets have been
vindicated no such wiretapping was going
on in the way that Trump misleadingly
characterized and Donald Trump just
needs a new distraction from the latest
disaster which is that Erik Prince the
brother of Betsy DeVos the Secretary of
Education
met with the Russians after the election
to create an unofficial back-channel
that's the real story and instead what
they're doing Pat is putting Susan Rice
in the spotlight for doing her job she's
in the spotlight because Trump wants
anybody in the spotlight in an effort to
distract unmasking private citizen names
from private phone calls when they are
legally intercepted is actually part of
her job as long as it's not being done
for political purposes we also know now
that if the Obama administration wanted
to sabotage the Trump campaign yeah they
could have done that because the FBI
breach them that they were investigation
Russia and collusion ties back in the
summer that's right and they decided not
to either out of their own hubris that
they were sure Hillary was going to win
or just this idea that it would affect
his legacy going forward remember folks
these distractions are coming from the
administration of the same man who
distracted us with Obama's birth
certificate for what was it three years
how long did the birther thing go on in
several years it started right after
obama got inaugurated yeah and it didn't
end right after that's for damn sure
this is a topic of conversation on our
reddit discussion forum I hope you'll
join us there at david pakman.com slash
re d di t we'll take a break Roger stone
joins me next today's program is made
possible in part by gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or Roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30 day free trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included no contracts and you can also
stream the game
I think I mentioned that you can also
rent games through the mobile app get a
free 30-day trial for david pakman show
viewers and listeners and support our
show at gamefly offer.com /td PS